نحن في smax tech نقدم
نظام مراقبة صحيًا لمزارعي الألبان
[موسيقى]
لماذا بدأنا هذا في الأصل هو أن
الكثير من المزارعين كانوا تقليديًا
صغارًا نسبيًا وكان المزارع يعرف
بالضبط الحالة الصحية
لأبقاره
ولكن مع نمو حجم المزرعة  أعداد الحيوانات الكبيرة التي
لا يستطيع المزارع إيلاء
هذا القدر من الاهتمام بعد الآن
للحيوان الفردي نفسه ، ويشبه جهاز الاستشعار الخاص بنا في
الأساس جهازًا
مناسبًا للحيوان ،
حيث تحصل كل بقرة على جهاز استشعار صغير
تبتلع البقرة جهاز الاستشعار ويبقى المستشعر
بشكل دائم في  شبكية
في معدة البقرة ،
يلتقط المستشعر جميع الإشارات الصحية من
البقرة
ويرسلها إلى المحطة
الأساسية وتجمع المحطة الأساسية بيانات
جميع الأبقار في القطيع ثم
تنقلها إلى السحابة
في السحابة ثم نطبقها  بياناتنا الضخمة
وخوارزميات الذكاء الاصطناعي لدينا
ويمكنها قياس أشياء
مثل تغير درجة حرارة
البقرة ونشاط اجترار البقرة
وكذلك دورات الشرب
ومستوى نشاط الكوب
ومن هذا نولد رسائل
وإنذارات للمزارع
بدون المستشعر ، فهو لا
يمتلك حقًا فهمًا عميقًا
للحالة الصحية الحالية أو الحالة الإنجابية
لحقنه الشرجية
ويمكنه التركيز عليه حقًا  هذه
الحيوانات ونقدم بروتوكولات معينة لتلك
الحيوانات التي تحتاج إلى اهتمامه في الوقت الحالي ،
نسمح للمزارع بأن يكون أكثر
إنتاجية مع قضاء ساعات أقل
وجعل البقرة
أكثر سعادة
لأن المكسيكي سعيد للغاية وفخور بأن يتم
عرضه في الجناح في المعرض على
وجه الخصوص  لأن الدول العربية لها
تقاليد أيضًا في تربية الألبان وهذا
آخذ في الازدياد ويمكننا إظهار
إمكاناتنا الكامنة في
بلد صغير نسبيًا مثل النمسا
ولكن مع التركيز على التكنولوجيا العالية والتكنولوجيا العالية
المنتجات الرائعة لهذه
المنطقة